as america reels from the worst drug
epidemic in our nation's history around
100 000 overdose deaths last year alone
up 29 in just a single year president
biden has unveiled his plan to stop the
carnage and the plan
is to give
free crack pipes to drug addicts
this public health strategy may seem
counterintuitive but the biden
administration insists that the
federally subsidized crack pipes will
reduce harm and advance racial equity
don't it always seem to go that you
don't know what you got until it's gone
back during the trump years i used to
complain when ivanka trump would
influence her father's policies
trump's children would nudge him to push
for paternity leave and criminal justice
reform and that was bad enough
but little did i know how i would long
for those days once hunter biden had the
ear of the president i'm michael knowles
it's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from alex shinprod
who uh
points out from this interview with
governor phil murphy democrat new jersey
governor murphy is there scientific
evidence that removing mass mandates
will work will jake political scientists
have measured that my favorability
rating will go up 6.8 by removing the
mass mandate that's true that is the
only science that is being followed on
the masks on the vaccine mandates on the
whole darn
thing
there are people right now who are
they're just trying to measure public
opinion and they're trying to present
their political agenda as though it were
the science capital t capital s one way
they do it is they collect a lot of data
on you when you want to keep your data
to yourself i would recommend you check
out expressvpn if you're listening to
this show some of you probably
check out some things on the internet
that you don't want people to find out
about you know what i'm talking about
i'm talking about those websites that
maybe you know i'm talking about like
dailywire.com that can get you in a lot
of trouble now you're probably thinking
well why don't you just use incognito
mode let me tell you something incognito
mode does not hide your activity doesn't
matter what mode you use or how many
times you clear your browsing history
say delete michael knowles show delete
speechless at amazon delete no you can't
your internet service provider will
still see every single website you've
ever visited which is why even when i'm
at home i always use expressvpn on my
computer and on my phone i've got it
it's right there it's super easy to turn
on with the click of a button doesn't
matter who your isp is in the us
they can legally sell your information
to ad companies expressvpn is an app
that reroutes your internet connection
through their secure servers so your isp
cannot see the sites that you're
visiting protect your online activity
today with the number one rated vpn
that's number one rated by business
insider visit this exclusive link
expressvpn dot com slash knowles you get
an extra three months for free on a one
year package exp or essvpn.com
knowles expressvpn.com knowles head on
over there to learn more this is what
they believe i i thought this crack pipe
story was just being exaggerated it's
not this is this is joe biden's plan to
tackle drugs is he's got all sorts of uh
new federal goodies that he's going to
give out
money for
certain treatments money for certain
facilities money for this that money for
that money for the other thing and money
for crack pipes
for safe smoking kits
is what they're called the the logic
here is if if someone really wants some
crack
then the most compassionate thing to do
for that person is to give them the
crack
this is the same logic behind if someone
is sexually confused the best thing to
do for that person is to mutilate that
person it's the same logic behind if a
person wants to commit crimes
if a person wants to say rob a store
then the best thing to do is just give
them space to rob the store open up the
gucci outlet let them go in take
whatever bags they want that's going to
let them blow off a little steam and
that will somehow
stop crime that will somehow restore
order the logic is whenever there is a
social pathology you indulge it and by
indulging it that will make things
better you never repress it repression
is really really bad you're not allowed
to repress your desire for drugs or
weird sex stuff or thievery or
any of the other things obviously it's
completely backwards but that's been the
dominant view from our elite
institutions for decades now and you're
seeing the effects of this there's a
video going around tik tok
uh every time i say that
ever i just i i myself get a little
chill up my spine nothing good generally
goes around tik tok there's a video of a
sexually confused man who i who i guess
identifies as a woman who now claims
that if you not only do we need to
indulge his delusions not only do we
need to indulge the crack addict and
give him pipes not only do we need to
indulge the thief and give him gucci
bags not only do we need to indulge the
sexually confused guy and pretend that
he's a woman
but if we do not actively participate in
that if we do not
sleep
with the sexually confused guy
we are bigots
so if the only reason you don't want to
date someone boils down to the fact
they're trans that's transphobia right
there let's go over a couple of
situations so if you don't want to date
a trans woman because you want kids well
you better be keeping that same attitude
with cis women who are infertile or
that's transphobia if you don't want to
date a trans woman because you're not
attracted to trans women i would
absolutely love to know how you're able
to identify correctly who is a trans
woman on-site 100 of the time because
that is just impressive i wish i had
that ability i'd love to be able to have
even more trans solidarity and then also
just
being super straight is the all lives
matter of sexualities it's not a real
sexuality it literally is just something
that's made up to make fun of trans
people and to hate on trans people so
yes super straights i don't respect you
and i don't respect that sexuality bye
if i found out today
that these videos are not being produced
in america they're not being produced by
just random people that these are all
being filmed in beijing
in xi jinping's propaganda studio to
disseminate throughout the west and
destroy our civilization i would be
about
seven percent surprised no three percent
surprised if
this is
really
really bad
it is and frankly it's even worse if
this is not just propaganda intended to
destroy our civilization because it
means that our civilization's already
been rotted out so much from the inside
that this is just naturally happening
the claim here
is that
if
if you
can tell the difference between a man in
a dress
and a woman
then you are
a bigot
he's really saying you can't no one can
tell the difference right he it doesn't
he looks like marilyn monroe doesn't he
you couldn't tell that line them up you
couldn't possibly tell the difference
right
and if you
if you want to uh
marry a woman instead of a man
pretending to be a woman
well
that's that's just evidence of your
small-mindedness what you mean because
women can conceive children and men
can't well then
what so you would never marry an
infertile woman well what is what do you
even mean by that what is
if you're telling me that the only
difference between men in dresses and
women
is that
women
can produce babies i mean that's a
pretty big difference but there are
other differences
as well this is clearly a disturbed
individual this is a man who's very very
confused about
himself about nature and about the rules
he should be helped a good society would
try to help this guy not to indulge his
delusion and his fantasy
a healthy society should should try to
help the crack addict not by giving him
crack not by giving him a crack pipe the
good society should try to help the
thief not by giving him nikes and gucci
handbags but by saying no don't do that
uh-uh that's bad
if you do that if you're a thief if
you're a crack addict if you mutilate
your body you're going to have a bad
life that's not going to help you
flourish and so we're going to help you
by laying out the rules men are supposed
to be men and women are supposed to be
women and men cannot become women and
women cannot become men and men and
women go together they are complementary
and they they come together and they
form a marriage and then they can
produce children and not everyone can
produce children it's a fallen world
there are imperfections we all suffer we
all carry our cross but that's th that's
the way the world is ordered there are
rules there is a purpose
not only to life broadly but to the
individual things in life and we can
know something about that purpose and
that's how we're going to order society
you're not allowed to say any of that
you're not if you try to help that guy
right now if you sat him down and said
hey buster you are not a woman it is not
wrong
or unjust or bigoted for a dude not to
want to sleep with you you need to you
need to stop pretending to be a woman
because it's not helping you or anyone
else and we're going to try to get you
some counseling if you did that
in canada you would be arrested
if that if that guy were your son and
you did that in canada you would lose
your son you might lose your kid here in
america in many places
if you were a teacher who said hey
you're not we want to help you and you'd
be booted out you'd be kicked out
you'd be fired
there's a law now in canada
if you sat down a guy who knows that
he's a guy
and said hey
you're actually a woman
that would be totally fine
you sit down that guy who thinks he's a
woman you say you're a guy you could be
arrested for it
there are still rules it's just that the
rules are are in the
direction of delusion and
falsehood so
the way we think of it now the way on
the left and on parts of the right
actually is that the rules are bad they
don't let us be free look if that man
wants to
pretend that he's a woman and mutilate
himself that's fine that's his right man
you know hey if the crack addict wants
to smoke a bunch of crack that's fine
and on the left they say we're going to
pay for you to smoke the crack and on
the right they say don't make me pay for
your crack but you can go smoke crack if
you want but both of those are wrong
don't smoke the crack okay that is these
are basic rules if you're a man don't
mutilate yourself and pretend to be a
woman and if you're a crack addict
put down the pipe do not take the pipe
the rules are not oppressive
repression itself is not oppressive if
repression is is repressing bad desires
that enslave you to bad appetites the
rules can be a great source of strength
and comfort
okay we've got to have some boundaries
around society just like around a like a
good ranch you know where you've got
delicious really high quality cattle you
need some boundaries
around that
and when i when i think about good
ranches i think about my friends over at
good ranchers 85
of the grass-fed beef in the united
states is not from the united states
it's imported from overseas but here's
the catch these foreign products are
often labeled product of usa
how do they do that that seems like a
lie well because if they're even
minimally processed here they get to say
it's a product of usa do not pay a
premium for low quality foreign meat
good ranchers sells 100 american meat
and delivers it to your door for a great
price they sell only 100 american meat
sourced from local american farms their
beef is prime and upper choice the
highest quality possible they got
ribeyes t-bones new york strips and more
i ate a couple of their strips the other
night it was absolutely fabulous loved
it they're pre-trimmed and pre-marinated
better than organic chicken breasts are
also terrific i just love them head on
over to goodranchers.com
knowles today to solve your meat problem
once and for all get the transparency
quality and cuts you've been craving
order now with code knowles get 30 bucks
off your box now is the time to support
american farms and ranches they are
hurting and you are hungry great it's a
win-win solve it with a box of american
meat delivered whoever buys the meat in
your house go to goodranchers.com slash
knowles today
if i found out that all these kooky tick
tocks are just propaganda coming out
from china and xi jinping i would not be
surprised speaking of china nancy pelosi
has a message for the united states
olympians who are competing right now in
china in the olympics that not a single
person in the entire world is watching
nancy pelosi says
yep china look maybe you think china's a
bad country maybe you oppose some of
their political views but i'm telling
you now i'm warning you
do not speak out
against the chinese government
i would say to our athletes
you're there to compete
do not risk
incurring the anger of the chinese
government because they are ruthless
i know there is a temptation on the part
of some
to speak out while they are there
i respect that
but i also worry
about what the chinese government might
do
to their reputations to their families
this is total concern trolling
this is so disingenuous
because what what she's saying is don't
criticize china hey guys don't criticize
china
but the reason you shouldn't criticize
it's for your own safety look i look
maybe i respect your views but just for
your own safety don't criticize
china
i'm just looking out for you
that's not why nancy pelosi and the
democrats are
tamping down on criticism of china it's
not why they didn't stop the chinese
olympics from going through that's not
why they are
are still supporting the importation of
lots and lots of goods from china and
outsourcing jobs to china
the democratic party is completely in
the pocket of china the united states in
many ways is in the pocket of china
china owns all of our debt they manufact
not all of our debt but they own an
extraordinary amount of our debt they
manufacture not all of our products but
an extraordinary number of our products
they're buying up a lot of resources in
the united states and they own
politicians that's just what they do
they've exerted an incredible amount of
influence over the past couple of
decades on both parties but especially
the democrat party
this is why when when donald trump tried
to even out trade between america and
china when he was engaging in that trade
where the democrats were horrified they
were clutching their pearls
he who pays the piper calls the tune and
the democratic party is owned by china
so now nancy pelosi says look just for
your own good
just don't don't criticize our overlords
in beijing please please don't do it
could you imagine
could you imagine if she said this about
the nfl players when they were
protesting our own country oh what a
breath of fresh air that would be
wouldn't that have been so wonderful if
nancy pelosi had one 100th the concern
for our own country and the disrespect
it was being shown by athletes as she
has for disrespect against communist
china
if she said hey you
ingrate athletes you millionaires
spitting on the american flag you colin
kaepernicks all the rest hey
stand up ingrates salute the flag love
your country or get out of the
oh my goodness oh that would be so
wonderful but she would never do that no
what did she do she got down on her knee
too
not in respect but in disrespect of the
star-spangled banner
we disrespect the stars and stripes and
we salute xi jinping
we do not do that but that is what the
democrats are doing
it's not this is not just a one-off it's
not even purely ideological it's a
structural problem with the democratic
party
would never do it blm
disrespecting the flag
speaking of racial politics
there's a new trailer
for a new show
on showtime it's going to delve into
some of the racial issues in america
and i haven't seen the show yet it
hasn't come out
but from what i gather
the thesis of the show
is that white people are really really
bad
i think what annoys me most about white
people is when they pretend like they're
the victim
what's also annoying is when they you
know when they kill us
what is fragile about whiteness when
everything has been constructed around
it
every part of who i am has been
distorted or criminalized it's really
just a bunch of white lies
we're starving
you're not patriots you're ridiculous
one of the definitions of american
whiteness is
ignorance
white people we are not your problem
you are should white people today feel
any responsibility for slavery
hell yeah
white jesus or black jesus jesus was not
white think of geography ain't no way
jesus walked around with blonde hair and
blue eyes
[Music]
those white people
those white people make me so mad white
people are
they're annoying
right that's that was one of the claims
just in this what 60-second trailer
white people are annoying
they're stupid they're ridiculous
they're ridiculous you ridiculous white
people they're ignorant that's the
definition of whiteness when you're
white you're ignorant so claims this
documentary on show time
you just you're just oh and you're uh
enslavers you enslave people
and you know the most annoying part of
all is when they play the victim
when they pretend that they're being
victimized you know
would seem to me
that
if we're in a society now
where the only racial group
that you are permitted to legally
discriminate against also you can sort
of discriminate against asians in
college admissions though it's
that's that's a little
that that's only because the asians got
lumped in with the whites that's being
worked out in the courts right now but
if basically it's the only racial group
you can legally discriminate against and
maybe more importantly it's the only
racial group that it is socially
permissible to insult constantly
including on television
i think you
you might be the victim group
look we're all you know it's a fallen
world we all suffer we got to deal with
it no one should
should view themselves as a victim but
if one of these groups is going to be a
victim
and you're going to make claims about
victim it would seem that the the that
the only racial group that you're
allowed to
discriminate against and go after and
treat like second-class citizens
that might be the victim group right
imagine the show i don't even want to
say it i don't even want to say it
because it's so it's so you roll your
eyes when you say
you know imagine if the shoe were on the
other foot but imagine just imagine for
a second you're watching the showtime
trailer that says you know the worst
part about black people
you know what really annoys me about
mexicans
you'd go you'd be sent to gitmo
you wouldn't just get your show canceled
you would be
you would be sent to some prison camp
somewhere
that would be so socially unacceptable
why so why why does this happen i think
white people i think they're the
majority of america still not by a lot
but still by a little bit so why why is
this i the reason for it is that
white people have a very low racial
consciousness there was a study that
came out of pew research not that long
ago that measured how
important race was
to someone's identity
and for black people it was over 70
percent
said it was somewhat or very important
for uh hispanics and asians it was over
50 and then for white people it was 15
just 15.
so it's just very very low
on the one hand what the left claims is
whiteness doesn't exist white people
it's a completely fake racial made-up
category and then on the other hand they
say
you are white you can never escape your
whiteness and you're evil because of
your whiteness and we're going to treat
you differently because you're white
obviously those are contradictory things
and the left is just trying to have its
cake and eat it too you saw at the end
probably the most
frivolous claim there was they bring up
jesus you say why are you bringing up
jesus
when you're talking about your crazy
racial diatribe they say man people say
that jesus is white no no actually what
they say is jesus said that jesus jesus
people say that jesus was white but he
wasn't white look at the geography
insinuating what that jesus was black
he jesus jesus is a jew
it's pretty clear if you read the book
it's pretty clear jesus is a jew when
you use the phrase jesus was
that's usually a red flag that the
person who is speaking does not know
very much about jesus or christianity
because jesus lives
that is the essence of the story that's
the essence of the religion is that he
rises from the dead
and lives
he is he's the divine logic of the
universe
he he is
the second person of the holy trinity i
am that i am
why do they bring up religion in this
crazy racial diatribe because it always
comes back to religion i do not
have a high racial consciousness i do
not consider politics
primarily or at all really significantly
through the lens of race
i consider it through the lens of
religion and in my religion there is
neither jew nor greek nor slave nor free
but all are one in christ jesus that's
the christian view of things the whole
idea of
racism and opposing racism it comes out
of christianity every other civilization
in the history of the world everywhere
on earth is very very very racist we're
the only one that's not
and and
now because the left is attacking
christianity trying to kick it out of
our society and out of the public square
this is what you're getting you're going
to get more of it more black
identitarianism more mexican
identitarianism you're probably going to
get more white identitarianism too
that's the future they want do you want
to be part of that no well if not you
need
you need an alternative kind of pile i
think i think we had a good one but the
left wants to get rid of it
you know when you want to
hear all sorts of interesting
conversations i would strongly recommend
you check out the jordan harbinger show
it's about time you checked out the
jordan harbinger show a top shelf
podcast named best of apple in 2018
jordan dives into the minds of
fascinating people from athletes to ceos
to government officials and to mobsters
and fbi agents harbinger has an
undeniable talent for getting his guests
to share never been heard before stories
and thought-provoking insights without
fail he pulls out tactical bits of
wisdom in each episode all with the
noble cause to make you a more informed
critical thinker to better operate in
today's world he's got this strangely
relatable weekly segment feedback friday
where jordan covers advice on everything
from psycho family situations to
relationships to networking he gives
great advice i always really really
enjoy the show you cannot go wrong with
adding the jordan harbinger show to your
rotation super interesting never a dull
show search for the jordan harbinger
show that's h-a-r-b as in boy i-n as in
nancy g-e-r as in really go check it out
on apple podcast spotify or wherever you
get your podcasts
and i think you'll enjoy it also
this is very exciting
you can join me
ben shapiro jeremy boring matt walsh and
andrew clavin
tomorrow night
7 30 eastern 6 30 central at daily wires
youtube channel
the premiere of shut-in
starts at 9 00 pm eastern on the same
channel so make sure to tune in before
then check out this trailer
now
you
must pay
your daughter
she's very pretty
i'm scared
the movie premieres tomorrow february
10th 9 pm eastern 8 pm central over
daily wires youtube channel make sure
you click the link in the description
turn on the notification bell so that
you don't miss it because after the
premiere it will only be available to
daily wire members we will be right back
with a lot more
there was a terrible racist attack on a
campus in illinois
terrible racist attack
on a black female student at southern
illinois university edwardsville
this young woman
found racist messages
written on the door
of her dorm
and uh there were two white students who
were accused of perpetrating this crime
and there were many calls for them to be
expelled what did the notes say the
notes said die
be it [ __ ] they said black people don't
belong
as a result of this some black activists
on and around the campus rallied for the
expulsion of these two white students
for perpetrating this this horrible
crime
guess what happened
i don't even need to tell you
you already know this story plays out
again and again and
again the girl wrote the messages
herself
it was a hoax it didn't happen
the minute i saw this story i knew it
didn't happen
i knew it didn't happen the minute the
left saw this story they said this is
evidence white supremacy the clan is
showing up again these are neo-nazis
anti-black skinheads
i said no i think it's a hoax
and i was right you know i hate to say i
told you so i was totally right
what is being reported now by the
college fix uh this uh black student has
been charged with three counts of
disorderly conduct for filing a false
police report what was the false police
report the false police report was about
these attacks
uh
there have been so many
of these hoaxes
these hoaxes
occur all the time i have a chapter of
my book speechless controlling words
controlling ones about these hoaxes
a lot of racial hoaxes a lot of sexual
hoaxes
so
what does this tell us
well it tells us some good news tells us
that white
white supremacism which we're told is
the central scourge the great injustice
of america it doesn't exist it's fake
lump it away with the tooth fairy and
the easter bunny if white supremacism
were real people wouldn't have to make
it up this girl wouldn't have to make it
up the many many many hoaxes that have
occurred in re recent years would not
have to be made up jesse smollette would
not have to hire two nigerian men from a
bath house to put on maga hats and say
this is this is trump country and then
attack him
while he was holding his subway sandwich
wouldn't have to do that because there
would there would be the klan wouldn't
there there'd be neon but it doesn't
that's not
real
the
reaction that people have to these
stories
is a really good barometer of their
ability to perceive reality i remember
uh years ago maybe right after trump won
a friend of mine very liberal friend of
mine
said michael i was driving i was driving
down la brea
in la
and i no he might have even been in a in
a nicer part of town i was driving and i
saw
someone wrote the n-word on a sign
you know get out n words or some
something to that if mike can you
believe this is trump's america this is
trump's america people are doing this
so hold on
west hollywood is trump's america it
kind of reminds me of downtown chicago
being mega country what do you
no michael it's people feel emboldened
they feel no do you know what it is pal
it's a hoax
it's a hoax and of course there were all
of these
attacks people painting all sorts of
things you know racial epithets on black
churches and what story after story
after story they were hoaxes
to
say well yeah look these incidents are
false but it gets to the deeper truth of
how racist and terrible america is
especially under trump no but it gets it
gets to your dishonesty what it gets to
is the huge chasm between your delusions
of what america is and the reality of
what's going on here
is a really good
barometer
you're you're you are seeing this play
out there there's a story michelle
malkin
who is a a long-time political
commentator
she was for a long time very mainstream
conservative she's gotten a little
fringier in recent years and
she has just been now booted
out of airbnb
neither she nor her husband are allowed
to stay
at any airbnbs from now on
i don't know if they're traveling pretty
soon they're not gonna they're not gonna
be permitted public accommodations
why well it's because
michelle malkin spoke at the american
renaissance conference
american renaissance is a white
identitarian conference
and uh i guess it took place last month
or
or a couple of months ago i guess no you
know what this this was from
yes this was from the end of 2021
and they airbnb rights airbnb's
community policies prohibit people who
are members of or actively associate
with known hate groups due to your
promotion and participation in a known
white nationalist and white supremacist
conference we've determined that we will
remove your account from airbnb this is
consistent with action we've taken to
ban people associated with this
conference in recent years and they're
banning her husband too because
sometimes she would book book hotels
under her husband's name
so michelle malkin is not allowed to
stay at
a new kind of hotel
because
she's a white supremacist and a neo-nazi
right basically now the the complicating
factor for this is that michelle malkin
is not white michelle malkin is filipina
so it's kind of strange for her to be a
white supremacist as a filipina and it's
it's really strange for her to be a
neo-nazi because her husband is a jew
so things aren't quite
matching up to the reality here are they
she did speak at this conference though
and the conference has a huge focus on
race and it's a white identity group
there's no question about that i'm not
disputing that at all
you can call it racist sure but it's no
more racist than any of the other racial
identitarian groups certainly no more
racist than black lives matter
certainly no more racist
than any of these other racial groups on
the left
and and by the way it has the advantage
over say blm or antifa of not having
ever burned the country down to my
knowledge to my knowledge they don't go
out and commit lots of crimes or
anything or arson or murder
they go they have their conference
they talk about ray and that will that
is enough to have you completely
ostracized from the public square
but if you do the same thing on the left
with the same kind of racial identity or
really frankly even more so
you're applauded
i do not think that racial identity is
the best way to view politics i think
it's kind of a creation of modernism of
modernity this idea that you view things
primarily through race i think it's
probably a much wiser idea to view
politics through religion
and specifically through christianity
the religion that built our entire
civilization and when our civilization
was healthy and thriving it was a
christian civilization and christianity
tamps down racism uniquely tams down
racism because older one in christ jesus
so i think we should do that
if you lose that though if you if you
lose that if you say no we're not a
christian civilization anymore we don't
even believe in god anymore we just
believe in stuff and on the left what
that means is we're just bags of
chemicals and we exist to get derived
pleasure and kind of screw around with
whoever we want and on the right you
just say and there are plenty of people
on the right who say look we can't know
anything about god we can't know
anything about even morality or ethics
all we can know is that we're material
beings and we need to increase our
economic output and consumption
right oh we we're just going to order
society toward being able to buy more
stuff
they're both kind of the same idea on
the left and the right it's just yeah we
just we're just kind of going to order
society around materialism well this is
what you're going to get okay
this is the consequence if you just make
everything about
matter
then this is what you're going to get or
by the way you're going to get the
complete opposite problem you're going
to get the transgenderism problem
which is you're going to say matter
doesn't matter at all and we're just
purely
spirits and we can just we we can
mutilate our bodies to if we're men and
pretend that we're women or better yet
we can just plug our brain stems into
the matrix and we're going to all live
in virtual reality where our bodies and
matter has no no meaning whatsoever the
traditional idea of civilization that
were body and soul inextricably linked
here in reality that's gone nobody is
allowed to believe that anymore
only those backward-minded christians
and jews and muslims i guess you know
only those backward-minded religious
people believe that but
but we smart moderns we believe either
one of these contradictory kooky things
well that's what you're seeing you're
seeing this right now with the
development of the metaverse
so facebook
which has changed its name now it's
called meta
and they have the metaverse
and we're all going to live in this
virtual reality and we're all just going
to be little cartoon characters in a
kind of video game world while we put
our goggles on and sit alone in our
little pods in our apartments
but we're going to live in this really
fun silly virtual world with a big
screen
well they're noticing there are some
moral problems here as well actually
meta just put put sexual harassment
guidelines in place
in virtual reality they announced quote
today we're we're announcing personal
boundary for horizon worlds and horizon
venues
uh personal boundary prevents avatars
from coming within a set distance of
each other creating more personal space
for people and making it easier to avoid
unwanted interactions
i called this you know how much i hate
to say i told you so i totally called
this when there was a video of what this
virtual reality world looked like the
the creepiest thing about the video was
that no one had any legs they were just
all kind of floating they were just
torsos up to their heads and everyone
was scratching their heads they said why
why aren't there any legs why isn't
there anything below the navel and i
said it's to prevent sexual harassment
they're going to actually desex
all the people which we're already
starting to do in our regular society
and we've been doing for 50 years
through the sexual revolution through
second wave feminism through the lgbt
lmnop movement now saying that men can
be women and women can be men we've been
trying to take sex away from human
nature and now you're just seeing that
represented in virtual reality
why because you know what's going to
happen people put on those goggles and
they say the moral universe doesn't
matter and they're all going to get a
little grab-happy with the avatars and
that's exactly what happened so now neta
is adding this boundary so you cannot go
up and pinch your friend
in in the metaverse and you know what i
say to that that's a good idea
that's a good idea i think the rules are
helpful
i think it is good to have boundaries
the the worst thing that could happen
with virtual reality is you put on the
goggles and you say i'm now i'm living
in a world where there are no rules and
it's not real it's not really real it's
like kind of a little bit real i am
using my free will but you know i'm not
it's not like it's not real life it's
not real stuff so i'm just gonna go and
and indulge whatever sick fantasies i
have whether that's killing a bunch of
people whether that's doing lots of
creepy sex stuff whatever that is i'm
gonna indulge all of my delusions
because it's just pretend world
it's like a lucid dream you know but
it's not going to have real effects
that's not good that's very corrosive to
the human soul to indulge that stuff all
the time
the left thinks it's helpful the the the
left believes that's the way to cure
social pathologies is yeah no blow off
that steam go smoke that crack go
indulge your weird sexual stuff go but
that isn't you need the rules i'm i
applaud facebook if we're all going to
live in this metaverse hellscape then i
at least think there ought to be some
good rules condor conducive to public
morals and virtue that sounds fine
speaking of
creepy sex stuff and
manifestations of evil there's a video
of a woman who was arrested down on our
southern border
for human smuggling and you know what
goes on there was a study came out from
the huffington post fusion amnesty
international some years ago it said
that 60 to 80
of women and the young girls who are
smuggled across the southern border are
sexually assaulted on the journey a lot
of them are put into sexual servitude
indentured servitude prostitution and so
one of these
these criminals one of these human
smugglers was arrested take a take a
listen
to her
reaction to the authorities
he's gonna close the door and stay right
there before we move
hey
calm down
they're trying to close the door she's
growling like gollum in lord of the
rings like like a demon
[Music]
she won't go you've got these huge guys
these huge border patrol agents and they
can't put push this lady who's
channeling some sort of demon back into
the van
this is
the moral reality of evil okay this is a
reminder that evil is not just some
physical
some some metaphysical abstraction from
physical reality it's not just the way
that we talk about things in the
physical world you know and we just try
to use it as a symbol to make sense of
things no there's evil there's real evil
and sometimes people just talk like
demons and sometimes people do evil
things like smuggle little girls and
force them into prostitution and it's
just it's and it can't just be indulged
and it can't just be mollified and it
can't just be slightly kind of
rehabilitated evil has to be
repulsed it has to be rejected outright
you've got to acknowledge that
evil affects physical reality this is
why when you've got the precious and the
precious it contorts your body
this is why when people do drugs and
drugs and drugs they just start to look
bad you can see the physical effects of
this and we've got to say it's a
beautiful two-letter word that we seem
to have forgotten we've got to say
no
speaking of being held to account for
the bad things
that people do
joe biden's science advisor
has just been fired
not dr fauci i wish it were dr fatchi
though we've got some great updates
there
you know i have the michael knowles
public health protection pledge to
for all federal candidates to say they
will investigate dr fauci
and zero out his salary if they can't
fire him they can at least take away his
salary
we've got
dozens and dozens of candidates who have
signed this we've got some some
interesting pretty big news on that
coming down the pike so stay tuned uh no
but unfortunately it was not fouchy who
got fired it was this other guy
there there was uh the top science
advisor dr eric lander has been under
fire for allegedly mistreating his staff
and he is now officially resigned
he he said quote
i have sought to push myself and my
colleagues to reach our shared goals
including at times challenging and
criticizing but it is clear that things
i said and the way i said them crossed
the line at times into being
disrespectful and demeaning to both men
and women that was never my intention
nonetheless it is my fault and my
responsibility i will take this lesson
forward so kind of a mealy-mouthed
squishy way to quit
i totally take responsibility i just
tried too hard
uh it's like in the job interview what
what's your greatest weakness my
greatest weaknesses i care too much i
just work too hard i can't strike a
work-life balance
i but okay but i but i take
responsibility
and he's gone
and this after days and days of
criticism because joe biden said i'm
never going to tolerate anyone being a
bully on my staff being abusive or
disrespectful we're not going to
tolerate that here and then he had been
tolerating it tolerating it from this
top science advisor so then he gave the
top science advisor the boot
that doesn't solve the problem this top
science advisor
was not the biggest bully in the biden
white house
the biggest bully in the biden white
house is joe biden joe biden gave a
speech
a couple of weeks ago
in which he said that half the country
were akin to nazis to bull connor to
vile evil terrible bigoted
unjust people
half the country
joe biden just told outright lies about
people joe biden who said that mitt
romney whose most ambitious campaign
pledge was to cut taxes a little bit
mitt romney wanted to put black people
back in chains
joe biden who took a 17 year old kid who
was being chased down by antifa lunatics
by felons and pedos and then in
self-defense shot them he
joe biden started his presidential
campaign
by calling that kid a white supremacist
with no evidence whatsoever and then he
was ultimately exonerated at trial the
biggest bully here is joe biden
and we should not let him
his personnel decisions moving around a
couple of people
have us lose sight of that
this guy
everything that he ever accused donald
trump of
he has got it 10 times over
now on the other side of accountability
so you've got the science advisor he's
got to be held accountable he's got to
go on the other side
you've got certain disgraced politicians
who are now being rehabilitated our
friends those hens at the view are
trying to rehabilitate
as some of us called it a a number of
months ago
you know i hate to say i told you so the
the hands of the viewer trying to
rehabilitate
love gov
andrew cuomo
there are reports that he's strongly
considering a return to politics maybe
even running for attorney general
against the woman who took him down
leticia james cuomo has always denied
any allegations against him and he was
never found guilty of a crime to be fair
but can he come back from this scandal
because he he kind of lost a lot of his
mojo in the public eye even if he wasn't
actually convicted i don't know that he
lost a lot of support from new yorkers i
think if you ask the majority of new
yorkers they feel that he did a good job
as governor especially handling the
pandemic when the trump administration
was not handling it well on a federal
level
um and you know i think there's the
other thing that he said
uh during his uh interview i think with
some with bloomberg
he said that uh tisha james was this was
a sort of a political prosecution
and i think there is something there you
know where there's some smoke there's
fire
am i living in an alternate reality
that new yorkers love andrew cuomo he
did a great job handling covid this was
he he didn't deserve to be kicked out he
he did a he's
no we've already
we've already been through that we've
already been through chris cuomo and cnn
and everybody saying andrew cuomo was
the greatest
greatest governor on on covet and and
ron death santos was the worst governor
on covet and then we got the numbers and
it turned out that that andrew cuomo's
policies directly led to the deaths of
thousands and thousands of elderly new
yorkers in nursing homes because he sent
sick people to nursing homes and then on
top of that
while andrew cuomo knew that his
policies were killing people he took
millions and millions of dollars to
write a book about how great he was on
kovid and then used state resources to
help write the book and then tried to
avoid getting an investigation from the
federal government which knew that he
was cooking the numbers on this dead
senior citizens
andrew cuomo was the single worst
governor in the country on kovit the the
death numbers the hospitalization
numbers were right there at the very
tippy top of the country
he was always in the top handful of
states for all of those things
and when you get down to his personal
decisions they were worse than anybody
else
and then what happened
they kicked him out of office for a sex
scandal
and i said at the time i said this is a
distraction don't let them get away with
this
they're going to have him go away for a
little while and say well maybe he
pinched his secretary but it didn't go
anywhere they didn't end up prosecuting
him now you've got people defending him
saying well there was never any proof he
did this i said it's all convenient
the whole reason they're doing it
is to distract from the real scandal
which is coveted and now they're going
to try to bring him back
that's what they're trying to do now
that was never the real scandal but
they're going to do it because andrew
cuomo always sticks up for the liberal
establishment
he's he he's in the club and they're
going to try and he might he might run
for attorney general which is the old
job he had he might run for governor
again
do not let them get away with this kind
of stuff
they are
they're never going to pay any
accountability it's amazing that you're
seeing this on the joe rogan week joe
rogan who has a much better record on
cover than andrew cuomo by the way by
orders of magnitude
joe rogan
contradicts the left-wing narrative
and they go after him and they throw the
kitchen sink at him and they said if you
quote it if you quoted someone else
saying the n-word a dozen years ago your
career has to be over oh but andrew
cuomo you i don't know maybe may or may
not have pinched your secretary or done
whatever and also you killed thousands
of new yorkers that's a little bit worse
that's fine you're cool
you're on the team
you're on do not
do not let them get away with this tune
out
they want they think they think we're
all smoking crack they want they they
think we're all smoking crack if we're
going to believe this they want us all
to smoke crack they want us to be mired
in delusion and vice don't do it you're
not going to get a good society that way
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022
[Music]
i'm
so sorry
now
sorry
[Music]
jessica
i can smell the weakness from here
rob
owes me money
let me out please
what is this doing now
you
had your way
i'm scared
now
you
must pay
your daughter
she's very pretty
[Music]
[Music]
you